[Applause]
often when we read textbooks about the
subject religions often presented as
these monolithic homogenous things this
is what a religion is this is how they
practice and so on but this kind of
description can in a lot of cases be
very problematic as it presents
something you know very simplified terms
that are in reality a lot more
complicated a religion is never really
monolithic or modernist it almost all
cases is comprised of a number of
different branches and schools of
thought and what we're doing when we're
presenting this kind of determined fixed
view of a religion is we're letting the
conceived mainstream or Orthodox
position represent the entire religion
in other words we're really ourselves
making a judgment as to what is the real
version of the religion and thus
undermining all sort of differing or
opposing viewpoints this is very
apparent in a religion like Islam for
example we often hear people say that Oh
Islam stands for this or this thing
where they believe in this net and this
comes both from Muslims themselves but
also from those criticizing Islam but
even some of the most basic foundational
ideas that we have about what Islam is
can become problematic take for example
the so-called five pillars of Islam this
is usually depicted as the most
universal aspect of Islamic teachings
and these five pillars are the Shahada
the proclamation of faith the pilgrimage
to Mecca fasting during Ramadan giving
charity and the five daily prayers the
problem is that not all Muslims follow
these five pillars for example these
smileys which is the second largest
group of Shia Muslims they have seven
pillars if we accept these five pillars
as a universal position with the within
Islam we are ignoring a lot of different
schools of thought and philosophies that
don't adhere to this idea to these
smiley Muslims the Shahada a
proclamation of faith is not actually
considered a pillar it is it is the very
basis of all Muslim faith
and it's just implicit in all of the
other pillars but beyond the Shahadah
the pillars of the Smiley's include the
Walia or guardianship then there is the
Tejada or purity there's a great
emphasis on purity and different
practices related to it the salat or
daily prayers the salat or charity
fasting pilgrimage to Mecca and lastly
jihad or struggle of course it should be
remembered that jihad doesn't
necessarily mean outer conflict or war
but must struggle generally in in the
faith with the exception of the Shahada
which as I said is considered implicit
and sort of as the basis of all the
other pillars the the the remaining four
pillars of the sort of Orthodox position
is present here as well although they
have changed over time another
significant aspect of the Smyly faith is
that most smile is today actually prayed
three times a day rather than five and
their prayer is also ritualistically a
bit different from the traditional Salah
prayer now if you believe that there is
a correct version of this religion or
any religion and that the Orthodox
position is that or the conceived
Orthodox position is that correct
version then by all means that is your
faith and that is a question of faith
but especially if we talk about this
from an outside perspective and in
academic or educational terms these
these kind of ideas are this kind of
rhetoric or this explanation of it
becomes very problematic becomes very
dangerous no one group or school of
thought can be said to represent an
entire religion they simply have a
majority of adherents sometimes not
always of course and have come into this
position of Orthodoxy for different
historical reasons but how can this
happen how can a religion be so
different and varied in their
interpretation of the very fundamentals
of the belief in terms of Islam which
can be said arguably to begin with the
life of the Prophet Muhammad and of
course Islam didn't really exist at the
time of the Prophet Muhammad but evolved
over their coming centuries we can see
very clearly
some cases how certain ideas that become
orthodoxy evolve over time the Prophet
Muhammad recited what is considered by
Muslims to be the Word of God but this
conception is also was rather
problematic and we will get to that
later in what is known as the Quran
which means basically the recitation
after his death and over the coming
centuries there was an explosion of
different interpretations and ideas
about this Quranic event and in this
early period there was no mainstream
where there was no orthodoxy because the
religion itself was still being figured
out there were theological schools like
the Motta's Allah who argued for a more
rationalistic logical reading of some
Quranic verses interpreting them
metaphorically and symbolically on the
other hand there was a group known as
two traditionalists who were a lot more
literal in their approach as well as
emphasizing the so called hadith a lot
more sayings of stories about the
Prophet a lot of the carrot caves the
the Abbasid caliphs were in fact
followers of the former school the more
rationalistic north as in a school but
for different historical reasons the
latter sort of eventually came into a
position of superiority and even though
sort of a synthesis was attempted with
another theological school later called
the asha rights the ash rights are
really a lot more closer to the
traditionalists than they are to the
Motta's Allah and so that's one step in
this kind of formation of of an
orthodoxy a mainstream orthodoxy that
evolved over these centuries
another famous divide within Islam is of
course that between the Sunni and the
Shia which stem back to a sort of
conflict of succession after the death
of the Prophet Muhammad some believed
that the prophet's friend abu bakr
should be the rightful temporal worldly
successor of muhammad and this is known
as the caliph while others believed that
the prophet's cousin and son-in-law Ali
was the rightful temporal and spiritual
successor of muhammad and the former
group who followed abu bakr became later
known as soon
while they later became known as she
which stems from the term she alley
which means party of alley now because
the Sunnis have historically always
basically held a majority position it is
their views that are often considered to
be Orthodox or mainstream and thus
variations that are present within the
shia of theology or philosophy are often
ignored by for example textbooks that we
find in schools when talking about Islam
the Shia believed and still believed
that the teachings of the Quran and the
Prophet Muhammad can only be interpreted
by his spiritual successors that belong
in a succession within his own family
known as the Allen bait and they used
several hadiths for example to support
this claim and this Lion of Imams which
is the name for these spiritual
successors begin with the prophet's
cousin and son-in-law Ali and his wife
Fatima and then go down to his son
Hussein and on and on for different
periods of time depending on which
school of shiism you follow and yes as
you may have guessed already there isn't
just one monolithic Shi branch either
but a bunch of different Shi isms as
well and I'm going to be focusing
primarily on one of them today which
begins with another sort of conflict of
succession after the the 5th imam ja'far
as-sadiq there was someone believed that
one of his sons musa al-qasim should
have been the rightful successor and
that line of your mom's that continued
after him became associated with a group
known as its national or the 12er Shias
because they considered there to be 12
Imams and the 12th Imam to have
disappeared gone into occultation and
will come back at the end of time this
is the form of Shiism that is most
prominent today and is sort of the state
religion of Iran for example but there
was another group who believed that the
rightful successor to jafar as-sadiq was
his other son is mild and this group who
followed this line of succession is
known at these smileys now the fact the
12er is nationally version dumb
yesterday is not hasn't always been the
case historically they're sort of
dominance in the Shia world really only
appears with the appearance of the
Safavid dynasty in Iran in the 17th
century before this the Smiley's were
also a significant movement within
Shiism I believe there are about 15
million today
the smiley is a nice mile ism is very
interesting not only because there is
sort of philosophy and theology
sometimes differ dramatically from from
other schools of thought but also
because they managed at one point in
history to create a sort of counter
caliph it's another Empire to oppose the
abbasids in Baghdad and this was a an
empire known as the Fatimid dynasty a
name that comes from the prophets
daughter Fatima who these Imams and
caliphs believed to be descended from
also significant related to this is the
fact that the caleb's of the fatima
dynasty were also the imams of the
Ismaili the community at the time so
they were often or and still described
sometimes as Calif Imams as being their
titles because they held both of these
positions
it was the Fatimids that founded the
city of al-qahirah which is of course
Cairo and also the University al-azhar
which still stands today and they were
also great patrons of arts and different
forms of knowledge it's a very
interesting period in early Muslim
history these miley's are still a
significant community there are two main
branches that are alive as of today one
of them is the Nizari Ismaili x' which
is the largest group and they actually
have still living imam xlix in
succession beginning with either the
Prophet himself or Ali but the 49th Imam
who is known as the Agha Hahn and is
actually a pretty prominent figure in
politics and so on today in the world
and there's another community beside
these in Saudis known as the Boris which
mainly exists in India today the Boris
don't have a living in mom as opposed to
the Saudis but they have a
representative of the Imam known as
by that that is sort of the leader of
this community now if you forget all
about these different branches and
complicated histories we can focus on a
very interesting aspect of smile ISM and
also by that return to our original
discussion about representation and that
is the the philosophical and theological
positions that is mai-lee's often held
historically and still hold today to
generalize a bit one can say that a
smile ism is heavily influenced by
Neoplatonic philosophy of course this
can be said to be true for basically all
early muslim philosophy but i believe it
is even more so when even more radically
so within the Aspire philosophy there
has generally been a great emphasis and
focus on the so-called baton reading or
that means sort of the inner or hidden
esoteric meaning behind the Quran and
certain Quranic verses as opposed to the
za here the exoteric or literal reading
of Scripture these - we'll often argued
that the words of the Quran were
addressed to a very specific audience at
a specific time as of course will many
other Muslims but that the it is the
moms that are the only people who can
really interpret what these actual inner
meanings the actual meanings are and
apply them to our given situation or a
given time and place this doctrine of
the baton aspect of the Quran and
theology and philosophy is so prominent
within a smile ism that a lot of
historians and philosophers contemporary
philosophers at the time described them
as the batty Nia or sort of the the
people of baton basically and they're of
course by a lot of these people
criticized for this emphasis on the
hidden aspects no where perhaps is this
more prominent than in the very idea of
revelation itself what is the nature of
the Quran and the revelation that
Muhammad received from God the
mainstream or Orthodox position thus to
nearest doc position can be said to be
this idea that the Quran pre-pre exists
eternally with God and that he gives
this Quran to the angel Gabriel who then
gives it to Muhammad
in Arabic by the way from the beginning
and then Mohammed just simply recites
what the angel told him it should be
remembered though that most of what we
know about the Quran its interpretation
its context how it should be understood
comes from later interpretations or
tough seed commentaries on the Quran or
to some degree on the later hadith
literature in other words how to
understand the Quran was also something
that evolved gradually over time as it
settled into a kind of Orthodoxy
eventually this includes the very idea
of the Quran being the literal word of
God that was recited word by word to
Muhammad in Arabic as well as the Quran
being considered a closed volume or book
and if we present this as the universal
positions that Paul Muslims believe we
are again letting the sort of Orthodox
mainstream position represent the entire
religion when in fact different are the
ideas a lot of different ideas have
existed throughout history regarding
this point these smileys for example
hold on to an idea of a completely
transcendent God and thus that God can't
speak words because both speech and
words are created instead some of them
offer a very different idea about
revelation for example writing in the
10th century the actual 14th Imam of the
Smiley's almos writes the following god
only revealed the Quran upon his servant
and His Messenger Muhammad as a light
Noor but the prophetic faculty carried
and that the perfect and purified soul
accepted when the Prophet may God's
blessings be upon him wished to convey
the light to the ranks of human beings
he realized that their natures were
dense and the turbid souls do not
perceive that satellite so he molded
that satellite but connected expressions
coined parables and understandable
allusions in order to make them straight
in their souls according to the
intention of the revealed wisdom since
the ranks of the people do not possess
pure Souls receptive to that lordly
Universal light here instead of the
usual narrative we have a revelation
that comes down in a form of a light in
the heart of the Prophet
and that is then conveyed in Arabic
words by the Prophet according to a
certain circumstance and Louis then goes
on to say when the Prophet composed
these expressions and these letters and
enclosed them the meanings that the
inspiration a word that's used is called
wha he contained the Quran constructed
upon this light which is the inspiration
became the speech of the messenger so
the composing the expressions and the
composition are due to the Prophet
thus the Quran is the speech of God
Kalam Allah and the word of the
messenger of God how allah rasoolallah
in a smiley philosophy this is then
explained using the Neoplatonic system
with a transcendent god that emanates
first the universal intellect and then
the universal soul and all the way down
to the sort of physical plane and the
revelation is explained using this
philosophical system of the intellect
and the Prophet receiving messages
through the intellect and so on it's a
complicated thing that I won't go into
here but one of the most famous
philosophers within the Smyly tradition
is a man named nasi Lucero he lived in
the 11th century and was both a poet and
a philosopher and a lot of other
different things and in his writings he
sort of promotes the Smyly viewpoints
and he in these writings he writes in a
rather similar way he meaning the
Prophet read to the people whatever they
were in need of from these science in
the divine writing and he concealed
these divine meanings in the Arabic
language by means of parables and
symbols clearly then this is in direct
opposition to the mainstream Sunni
position with the Quran pre-existing
with God and descending upon Muhammad in
Arabic from the beginning and in fact
this sort of mainstream idea was rather
offensive to a lot of these Smiley's as
they thought it went against all
rationality and logic it should be
remembered however that even the Sunni
position that I'm talking about was also
something that evolves over time and
wasn't at all a fixed idea from the
beginning in the
early years of the religion questions
like this and debates like this were
still vibrant
with people holding many many different
positions and then over time a certain
viewpoint was favored over another for a
certain historical and social reasons
that I could make a whole other video
about and there's a lot of research on
this that's very interesting
that sort of sheds light on the
development of sort of Islamic orthodoxy
we can't know for sure which is the sort
of correct position if there is a
correct position but what I'm trying to
say here is that a regardless of what
Orthodox Muslims or indeed school
textbooks try to tell you there is
nothing that says that the official
interpretation of Scripture of a
religion is more correct than any other
the Quranic revelation and Islam in
general and really any religion has been
interpreted in a multitude of different
ways throughout history and today these
smileys and other groups within the
larger Islamic context as well as other
groups within other religions has just
as much right to represent the religion
as does the apparent mainstream
orthodoxy and we should be careful not
to fall into the trap of simplifying or
creating a monolith of something that in
reality is a lot more multifaceted I'll
see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]